we can all relate to the fact that our
minds have at least two modes of thought
one is driven by sense and feel the
intuitive part it happens fast and
automatically the other is driven by
concepts the logical part it's slower
and happens in steps you can think of
the logical part of your mind as your
ability to think in sentences while the
intuitive part is your ability to think
with feelings by the mid 20th century
computer engineers are trying to build
machines which simulate both kinds of
thought using two entirely different
approaches what we now call computers
were focused on analytical thinking
designed to automate what humans say
they do when they think the other
approach was focused on automating
intuition machines that can sense the
world from direct experience known as a
neural network unlike computers neural
networks were designed to mimic what
actually happens in the mind at the
cellular level during thought but the
stuff of the mind remained a mystery
until the late 1800s when our tools
finally allowed us to look very closely
at this squishy mass in our skull Kajol
famously started investigating slices of
this brain tissue very closely by
injecting dye into the nervous system to
see its structure it turns out the brain
tissue was not at all a solid mass but
composed of a dense mesh of connected
cells called neurons neurons are
communication cells that evolved to send
signals within a body they constantly
fired in chain reactions like a
microscopic electrical storm
to generate our thoughts and feelings
the meaning behind these electrical
patterns is still a mystery today but
from an engineering perspective this was
exciting because the entire mind seemed
to be built out of one repeating thing
the neuron
and neurons were similar to existing
electrical components we use everyday
signal boosters or relays by applying a
weak electric current to the input side
of the device above a certain amount
flips a switch and sends a separate
electric current down the output think
of it as a switch which instead of
physically pushing you trigger with
electricity
eventually we shrunk these devices down
to the head of a pin
called transistors McCulloch and Pitt's
famously defined how you could build a
biologically inspired neuron out of
existing electrical switches their
neuron design would receive a set of
signals using as many wires as you'd
like and if together they hit a certain
threshold around the same time it would
send a signal down the output lines and
they showed how you could connect
neurons together in small networks to
perform simple functions and computation
takes the form of groups of neurons
firing together creating a parallel wave
of electrical activity which passes
through the network and these patterns
of neuron activations are defined
entirely by the connections between
neurons so the connection pattern is
like the program of a neural network
this theory was best summarized in 1952
by Hayek in his first book the sensory
order the question he started with was
how to establish a connection between
the patterns of energy in the outside
world which we sense and the resulting
patterns of energy inside our minds he
viewed things as follows first there is
some physical wave of energy which hits
our senses whether it's a pattern of
light hitting photosensitive cells in
our eyes or sound hitting sensitive the
hairs in our ears called
a stimulus this stimulus creates a wave
of electrical pulses which travels down
connections into our minds
he called this the primary impulse it is
like the raw data of the stimulus that
our mind has access to this leads to a
second group of neurons which activate
and send off another wave of electrical
pulses which he called the secondary
impulse and this sets off a third group
of neurons creating another wave of
energy and so on
each step or layer in this process
transforms a signal further to extract
meaning because as perceptions progress
through these layers they differentiate
or separate from each other into unique
patterns of neuron activations deeper in
the network for example the stimulus of
a cat versus a dog would stimulate
similar neurons in the first layer but
they would begin to separate out as they
pass through these layers and activate
very different groups of neurons deeper
in the mind where meaning is extracted
so when you see a cat there is no cat
signal flowing down a single connection
and activating a single cat neuron
instead the idea of a cat takes the form
of a unique group of neurons which
activate at the same time this is known
as a distributed representation another
example of a distributed representation
is a musical chord it's a group of notes
which are activated at the same time
where notes are like neurons a chord is
like a concept we recognize it's based
on a pattern between notes not any
specific note and these unique groups of
neurons trigger different mental
feelings in our minds to get a sense of
what I mean by mental feeling take a
look at this image it contains two
different things depending on your
interpretation you can actually feel the
flip or clunk happening in your mind as
it toggles back and forth between these
two different interpretations it is a
result of different neuron activations
in the deeper layers of your mind so
whether it's a shape or color or a
person's voice or handwriting we can
feel differences or similarities
mentally and so once we develop a sense
for a certain kind of perception we can
then attach a word to that feeling known
as conceptualization this categorization
of our perceptions into feelings we can
recognize and attach words to we call
generalization or abstraction and it's
nice to think of abstraction as the
counterpart to our annoying
habit of forgetting specific details the
writer bore hey tried to bring this to
life in his famous short story about a
man who didn't have this ability to form
abstractions instead he had a perfect
memory
he remembered not only every leaf of
every tree of every woods he knew by
heart the forms of each cloud the
outlines of ripples and water from days
past but this power came with a downside
because he noticed every difference
everything was different to him in fact
his own face surprised him every time he
saw it in a mirror it was difficult for
him to comprehend that the symbols of
dog embraced so many unlike individuals
of size and form and beyond that it
bothered him that a dog at 3:14 seen
from the side should have the same name
as the dog at 3:15 seemed from the front
and so he couldn't filter his
perceptions into concepts based on
shared patterns and attach a word to
them so the dream connectionists were
left with was the creation of an actual
machine which could form its own
abstractions by making connections
between perceptions this is what Frank
Rosenblatt set out to build the first
working model of a neural network in
1958 he started with a simple problem of
learning to recognize handwritten images
of circles or squares his first attempt
at a machine was constructed out of
three layers of neurons the first layer
he called the sensory units which
connected to the retina which reads
pixels in an image and for how to
connect the neurons he looked to how
nature formed the connections each sense
unit only connected to a nearby cone of
pixels which is what we observed in cat
eyes for the other layers he simply used
random connections since he knew that
the structure of the connections must be
learned from experience and the final
layer was the response layer for example
there would be an output neuron to
represent a circle and another to
represent a square each connected to a
light at the end to signal its
activation and the learning was made
possible with knobs which were attached
to every connection that could adjust
the connection strength by adjusting the
flow of electricity exactly like a
dimmer switch this was a mechanical
version of how the brain makes stronger
or weaker connections between neurons to
train the network he first exposed it to
an example he generated this would
activate the retina and caused a unique
wave of neuron activations to pass
through the network leading to some
output at first this output would
usually be uncertain which is when both
output neurons light up or neither of
them do next he wiggled each knob or
connection wait to try and force the
correct output neuron to activate
starting at the output and then working
backwards through the network and then
he would repeat this process with new
examples and this training process ends
when you hit a point where there is no
tuning needed to get a better output
prediction the network just works
Rosenblatt said that abstraction or
generalization must have occurred at
this point plus it on that algorithm
works that's a very naive view of
evolution but it works it's
communications you're doing and if you
just do that long enough you'll get a
network that does good things
once the connection weights are set you
can consider the neural network as being
programmed for the task the problem was
his machine only worked on the most
basic perceptions such as centered
images of 2d shapes but then he
challenged it by moving the shapes
around and rotating them to create cases
where perceptions in the same category
shared no common pixels in these cases
the network failed it was simply too
much difference for the net to handle
but more importantly when he instead
created a brand new layer in the network
and added new connections to it it was
then able to solve more difficult
problems because it creates an extra
processing step in the activation
pattern which allows more complex
patterns to be differentiated that's the
key his experiments confirmed what
others had predicted adding more layers
to a network gave it more abstract
should power this is the essence of what
we now refer to as deep learning today
Rosenblatt ended his papers with dreams
of neural networks large enough to
understand images and sound instead of
his toy examples the key hurdle standing
in his way
was the time required to train the
network using his methods the problem is
that I have to run a whole bunch of
examples through the network actually
twice for each weight and I might have a
billion weights so what we want we want
to do that algorithm that's the basic
algorithm you're gonna tinker with
weights and just keep the tinkers a
change but it's hard to do it
efficiently
for example networks which are big and
deep enough to process images would take
hundreds of thousands of years to Train
using his methods you'd be stuck
wiggling knobs forever but over the next
60 years there was some major advances
which made massive neural networks
suddenly very fast to Train and it boils
down to a change in the neuron model
Rosenblatt originally used the binary
neuron model where the output was either
all or none based on hitting a certain
threshold what we call a step activation
function but instead what was needed as
a neuron with an output that changes
more gradually with input for example
turning on at one threshold and ramping
up more gradually and this changed how
error information could be extracted
during training because remember with a
simple binary function when you wiggle a
knob inside a network it'll usually just
do nothing to the output or in some rare
cases it will turn the output neuron on
or off if it happens to push it across
the activation threshold and so the only
thing you might learn when wiggling a
knob is what direction to turn it but
with a smoother activation function when
you wiggle a connection knob you get a
gradual or proportional change to the
output neuron and this allows you to
determine the direction and the
magnitude of change to that neuron
needed to reduce the output error and
this extra information is the key to
improving the training process because
it allows us to tune the connection
as a group instead of one at a time
first we take a random example from the
training set as before and expose it to
the network then we wiggle each
connection wait in the network as before
but without making any final change to
it in order to figure out the exact
impact on the output error this tells us
how important each neuron is in
contributing to the overall error and
once we have this information for every
neuron we then do a final backwards
calculation pass through the network to
add up the interconnected impact of all
the connections on each other and then
finally we can perform an update to all
the connection weights as a batch in one
step so in the same amount of time is
the mutation algorithm can figure out
what's true is one wage we can figure
out what to do with all the weights and
if there's a million weights that's a
million times more efficient when a
million times more efficient enough to
make a difference so for example what
would have taken hundreds of thousands
of years to Train would now take hours
the other key advance came around 2009
and it was a hardware improvement when
we switched to using graphical
processors called GPUs to perform these
calculations because graphical
processing units were designed to do
many calculations in parallel this
allowed them to crunch the numbers
across a network 10 to 50 times faster
and this led to what has been called the
Big Bang of deep learning it led to
massive neural networks we can train
that can perceive images video and
physical space in ways people had been
dreaming about for a hundred years and
many thought not possible but today we
accept that the dream of connectionism
works neurons connected together
randomly in layers can learn to
configure their connections based on the
patterns of their experience in order to
divide complex perception into discrete
categories or concepts but we still have
trouble proving mathematically why they
work so well what is going on inside a
neural network from a math
manacle perspective how do we formally
define what the concept of a dog is from
the perspective of a neural network and
secondly how do we extend this intuitive
style of computing to encompass logic
and handle problems which are sequential
in nature
[Music]